إلهام Spacex
[تصفيق]
نيابة عن Spacex
world من حولهم ، شكرًا لك على مشاركة
قيادتك ، الأمل في الكرم
وإلهام الرخاء للطاقم ،
أول صور مهمة مدنية بالكامل
تستحق عن
جدارة وهنا يأتي التنين الذي يخرج من الماء
وكأنه بدأ  لغسله ،
اجعله نظيفًا جاهزًا
لفتح الفتحة ،
نعم ، هذا في الأساس مخرج أو
منصة
لأعضاء طاقم um للخروج من تنين أم تنين كبير
جدًا والفتحة الجانبية طويلة جدًا وبالتالي لا
نريد أن نتأكد من أنه
عندما نفتح الفتحة الجانبية يمكنهم
الخروج بشكل مريح
وما لديهم هناك
وهناك هي
الضابطة الطبية haley arsenault قد
خرجت الآن من السيارة أول
مصدر إلهام للطاقم الكثير من الموجات
رائعة
[  الموسيقى
] وهذا هو كريس سيمبروسك مرة أخرى
المتخصص في المهمة
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هناك متحمسة للأطباء
السماويون ، أنا أحب ذلك ،
أحبه
[ضحك]
مباشرة لا أعرف أي مشكلة  م
[تصفيق
] وهذا هو كريس سيمبروسك مرة أخرى
متخصص المهمة
[موسيقى]
مرة أخرى بابتسامة على وجهه
متحمس للغاية على استعداد للذهاب